hey guys i'm philip molina and if you're
like who the hell is this guy where's
the other guy you might want to watch
our channel update video he's not going
anywhere though anyway you were here for
the spider-man post-credit scene
explained let's talk about what they
were but more importantly what they mean
like what they could be predicting about
the future of the MCU now if you haven't
seen the movie why do you do this to
yourself
spoilers guys spoilers incoming oh and
at the end of this video I'm gonna fill
you in on some alternate post-credit
scene ideas that I think would have been
really cool to see - it's a grand for
those okay that was sufficient time for
you to pause the video before spoilers
let's get to it
post credits scene one this scene opens
in a prison where we see tombs has been
sent following his capture walking down
the hallway he runs into a familiar face
Mac Gargan
except I'm gonna call out he's not like
the most familiar face he's in the movie
for like 10 seconds on the Staten Island
Ferry scene before he gets knocked off
into the Atlantic Ocean Gorgon tells
tombs that there's a rumor that he knows
spider-man's real identity and that he
has friends on the outside who would
love to slice Whitey's throat open put
his head in a dryer which is like the
weirdest threat but okay then the kind
of surprising moment is that tooms
doesn't give up Peter Parker's name he'd
lies and says that if he knew who he was
spider-man would already be dead
so as far as post-credit scenes go that
seemed pretty straightforward and most
of the purpose of the scene definitely
is to show that the vultures got in his
heart back and he feels like he owes
Peter for having saved both him and his
daughter but it's the MCU you know
there's a lot more going on here take a
close look at Gargan and you might have
noticed this in this scene or Dannette
oh so brief glimpse earlier in the movie
but this guy is a big ol neck tattoo of
a scorpion now if you already know your
Spidey villains then you know the name
Mac Gargan is the alter ego of the
Scorpion the Scorpion was originally a
private investigator hired by Jay jonah
Jameson to find out how Peter Parker was
always getting such great pictures of
spider-man and he sucks as a PI because
he can't get ahead of Peter spidey sense
so Jay jonah Jameson somehow convinces
them to go through a crazy science
experiment it gives him like 10 grand it
of course drives him insane and you know
gives him some scorpion abilities but
the version we see in the movie actually
lines up a lot more with the version of
scorpion from be ultimate marvel
universe that's where Miles Morales is
spider-man instead of Peter there he's a
tatted-up Mexican crime boss and a
former associate of the Prowler just
like in the movie he wants to become a
new version of the kingpin and you know
run the New York crime scene as we all
do okay so here are two reasons why
really focusing on scorpion here and the
post-credits is fascinating first you
know how sony is making a venom movie
that has nothing to do with spider-man
yes it confuses me too that has a lot of
people bummed out cuz that could mean
that Spidey and venom won't ever collide
and that's a real damn shame but in the
main spider-man run a comics about ten
years ago maybe you know what character
becomes venom Mac Gargan now I'm not
saying that this means that he will
become the MCU version of venom and that
Tom Hardy will be the Eddie Brock's only
only only only version of venom I'm just
saying it's not too crazy to imagine
that the MCU story could invent its own
version of the symbiote that still
enhances Scorpions powers in a very
venom like way and then it's not just a
repeat of spider-man up against another
guy with cool technology that's based on
a natural predator it can instead be a
literally insane individual who often
dreams of cannibalism and who's slimy
exterior can actually form a real
scorpion tail Plus have like all of
spider-man's same powers - okay that's
reason one that focusing on scorpion is
interesting here's the second reason say
we toss out the venom inspired idea
Gargan is still a major crime boss when
he says he has friends on the outside
he's not talking about low-level idiot
thugs he's probably talking about other
big players in the crime world so this
group of friends that all wants to toss
spider-man's head into a dryer they all
sound a lot like the sinister six the
sinister six is a group of spider-man
villains who all put aside their own
criminal exploits and decided to put all
of their attention towards straight-up
murdering spider-man think John wick -
but only six assassins honey in our main
guy well six crazy super-powered
assassins and this movie already
established how this group could become
a huge threat remember that Gargan was
in the market for Chitauri based weapons
and remember that the genius behind the
designs Phineas Mason he's still m.i.a
he could be out there and in the comics
mason is actually a major character
himself known as the tinkerer and the
tinker is known for creating tech for a
bunch of villains for instance and a
bunch of stories he's the guy that
designed Mysterio suit and when I tell
you that the original lineup of the
sinister six includes vulture Mysterio
electro and Doc Ock you could totally
see how the tank
could really connect them through all
his stolen tech now scorpion himself
wasn't part of the original lineup but I
wouldn't be surprised if he replaced
someone else on the team like Sandman
who's a villain we already saw Spidey
take on pretty thoroughly I know he also
fought Doc Ock and electro already I'm
just saying scorpion could sub in
somewhere in the lineup one person
though I hope he doesn't replace him the
original lineup is Kraven the hunter I
think that guy's awesome his thing is
that he's just like the world's best
hunter and he's bored by hunting
anything that isn't extremely difficult
to catch hence his obsession with
spider-man now about that original
sinister 6 lineup they're fun and a
while later there's a version where
Kraven gets replaced with Hobgoblin I
think as Craven is dead during that time
actually but they'd have to work on the
storyline a little bit the first
incarnation of them has them kidnapping
Betty Brant who is in the movie she's
that super awkward morning announcements
girl but then also when it comes time
for Spider Man to fight the sinister
sticks what do you expect to be this
insane six on one unfair fight they all
just really stupidly fight them one at a
time
even though spider-man can obviously
beat each one of them up individually
already it's so silly that in this
awesome
hilariously meta moment from the freakin
old comic spider-man still totally calls
it out he's like oh why didn't you guys
team up against me it's very dumb also
there's a more recent version of
synergistics I was active during the
Civil War saga I'm not really a big fan
of that lineup so it's not really worth
mentioning take my word for it but I'm
just gonna put this out there Marvel
don't worry about that version at all
either they are boring as hell they
don't even get to feed it on the comic
book page caps Avengers handle them off
the page while we look at more
interesting stuff a few last things I'll
say about the sinister six possibility
specifically first it would all come
down to casting in a balance story the
actor playing scorpion he's a relative
unknown so you got to imagine that the
rest of the villains could actually be
like really big name stars in fact I
would love to hear your casting ideas in
the comments who would play these people
but then the art of the balance story in
superhero films it is famously difficult
to balance too many villains now good
screenwriting has shown that you can
still make a lot of people work when it
becomes a - point of view story this
versus that us versus them and that's
why a ton of villains that all share the
same POV can work - League of Assassins
anybody but in this case why simplify
these villains - all being just multiple
sides of the same diamond I
probably prefer that we actually pulled
off on the sinister six
instead develop each villain that is
worth developing on their own then bring
some of the better ones back in the
third spider-man movie spider-man
graduation yeah also I'm gonna throw out
there the sinister six rights issue is
very complicated you might remember that
Sony consider doing a standalone
sinister six movie kind of like Suicide
Squad without spider-man a while back
and then they can't pull it because a
lot of interesting drama there too but
we'd have to get into that another time
point is stupid studio rights might even
prevent that story from actually
happening to now because it's illegal to
only do one post-credit scene these days
let's talk about the second scene that
was packaged all the way at the end of
the final credits
Captain America pops out on that white
background that we saw in the videos
that were sprinkled throughout the movie
and he tells us about the virtues of
patience it's a complete troll moment by
Marvel the movie is well over two hours
long they know your bladder is on the
verge of Hindenburg II and they know you
sat there waiting and waiting through
all these names that you were not
reading and then instead of giving you a
tease of maybe infinity war or black
panther or what a lot of people are
expecting we get this I thought it was
hilarious actually it's fun to point out
really quick I'm not in high school
anymore uh so I hope this is still the
case but these PSAs were such a real
thing except they started the equivalent
of Avengers in our world NBA players and
wrestlers don't do two out if you're
doing it stop it
don't smoke choke no caps actually
reminded me the most of one PSA I think
I remember from like elementary school
it was Schwarzenegger in gym class and
for some reason Zack Morris was there to
know here to help me cuz pump you up on
my friends mock mock Paul Ronda and oh
that's right Mixmaster be finally
alternate post-credit scenes that i
think would have been badass this was
someone else's idea but they wanted to
see j jonah Jameson demanding pictures
of Spidey except it would still be
played by JK Simmons because he was
basically perfect partner hello you're
fired
so I'm also down for Hugh Laurie J Donna
myself that that's just me but here are
three ideas that I came up with that I
think could have been really fun and
could still work at some point in the
future maybe one we seen ed and Peter
geeking out in Peters bedroom over a
news report it's an announcement from
NASA that we're finally sending a
mission to Mars or some planet cooler
than Mars
and I bet some of you already ahead of
me on this because that would be the
mission that would eventually lead to
the symbiotes coming to earth so I'd
know I love the idea that the movie life
could have been this story on its own
like a venom prequel but c'est la vie
that's never gonna happen but also none
of this idea can happen because of
stupid studio right stuff idea - a silly
MCU post-credits scene that shows Tony
Stark just can't let a good suit go to
waste and he takes that awesome iron
spider armor out for a spin but since
Robert Downey jr. is probably like 10
million dollars a minute let's just say
it's happy that does it instead and he's
really not good at it actually maybe
even like he tries to touch the armor
and it does that crazy iron spider arms
range by the way this will reveal of
this suit and the press conference was a
huge easter egg referencing the Civil
War comics but Eric will tell you more
about that in our whole spider-man
breakdown video they just watch after
you watch this video if it's come out
already okay my third idea and it's
actually my favorite one almost the same
scene with tooms he's new to prison he's
settling in he has a conversation with
another prisoner and he's talking about
his pain-in-the-ass webcrawler and while
he still does the right thing of not
outing his identity he does talk enough
smack to really make the name spider-man
stick in this guy's head as someone
who's definitely gonna be a problem for
him when he gets back on the outside and
when we finally see who the other inmate
is boom kingpin finally reconnecting the
broken relationship between Marvel
movies and TV shows and doing it with a
villain who I think has a fascinating
relationship with spider-man alright
those are my ideas and if you think
those pitches I came up with for
post-credit scene sound fun maybe you'd
be interested in supporting my pitch for
a TV show that's currently competing in
a TBS contest about a kid who isn't too
different from Peter Parker in fact his
name is Miles who may have just made
Earth's first contact with
extraterrestrials if you want to know
more about it go ahead and watch my
pitch for it I did at VidCon that's why
it's noisy in the background by the way
but summing it up quickly I'll say
imagine if the guys from Silicon Valley
had to figure out both how to talk to
aliens and what the hell to say to them
this is the contest so if you feel like
voting I would really appreciate it and
hey if you feel like voting every day
once per day then I would probably owe
you something it's only until July 13th
and I have to be in the top ten for my
idea to make it to the next round with
your help maybe we could get that show
made I don't know but thanks for letting
me talk to you about a per second oh and
speaking of pitches I want to know your
ideas for great spider-man post-credit
scenes - leave them in the comments I'll
be in there rubbing up elbows with you
all shortly
I've been Phillip Molina thanks so much
bye-bye